bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public et la
nouvelle émission de public sénat
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité et qui se met au service des
citoyens en tout cas c'est notre
promesse et on va essayer de la tenir
tous les soirs avec deux débats un thème
d'actualité pour commencer et puis un
peu avant 19h le choix de la rédaction
plus prospectif plus décalé de
l'anticipation un droit de suite des
débats de société et entre les deux il
ya notre rubrique les électeurs ont la
parole vous pouvez d'ailleurs réagir
d'ores et déjà avec le hashtag
#civsocial hic sur tous les médias
sociaux voici les titres de ce mercredi
anne hidalgo rase gratis si elle devient
la première présidente de notre histoire
elle propose de doubler les salaires de
toutes les personnes en contact avec les
élèves d'ici à la fin de son quinquennat
joli coup politique pour les un futur
sparadrap promesses intenables dans sa
campagne pour les autres c'est notre
débats d'actu dans les électeurs ont la
parole on part dans le gard auprès des
sinistrés des inondations vous entendrez
des habitants un représentant des
pompiers mais aussi on reviendra sur les
inondations d'octobre 2015 dans les
alpes-maritimes notamment à mandelieu la
napoule avec le maire pour savoir ce qui
a changé dans la ville depuis ce drame
qu'elles le sont il en a tiré et puis
notre débat a décalé le choix de la
rédaction on sort de l'actualité
brûlante pour découvrir la radioscopie
de la jeunesse française
désenchanté insaisissable au coeur de
l'urgence climatique et les multifaces
symbole de plusieurs fractures selon les
et les auteurs de cette étude 2
l'ifop
anne hidalgo don qu'elle déroule dans
cette campagne présidentielle avec une
proposition choc pour faire parler
d'elle c'est réussi pour concentrer les
crises il est critique j'y arrive pour
concentrer les critiques aussi c'est bon
j'espère iv 0 marié
rien de tel pour lancer une campagne que
d'imposer une proposition choc c'est le
choix qu'a fait anne hidalgo en
dévoilant sa promesse de doubler le
salaire des enseignants français sur un
quinquennat si elle était élue à la
présidence de la république
immédiatement la mesure a provoqué des
réactions de ses opposants politiques
cette mesure coûterait 150 milliards
d'euros à la fin du quinquennat s'est
emporté jean michel blanquer air dans
les colonnes du parisien ajoutant que
l'élection présidentielle ne peut pas
être une foire du trône de la démagogie
démagogique aux choix politiques quoi
qu'il en soit la mesure fait parler et
sur un thème l'éducation pas souvent
mise en avant par les candidats quand on
est candidat à la présidentielle il faut
être entendu il faut porter un projet et
anne hidalgo veut que l'éducation soit
au coeur de ce projet parce que il ya un
décrochage français et c'est le
diagnostic qu'elle pose et puis c'est
une dimension essentielle si nous
voulons donner redonner à la république
tout son sens oui les enseignants
français sont bien moins payés que leurs
homologues allemands par exemple
mais pour laurent lafon président
centriste de la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation du sénat la
rémunération ne doit pas être l'alpha et
l'oméga d'une politique éducative le
risque de ces effet d'annonce c'est
justement de réduire un sujet assez
complexe à uniquement une question
salariale combien même elle se pose elle
se pose réellement si ça pouvait être un
sujet de la campagne ça serait
évidemment très bien et il faut que ce
soit abordée de manière raisonnable et
responsable
la proposition de l'actuel maire de
paris en tout cas attiré tous les
regards de ses opposants comme des
syndicats enseignants le défi pour anne
hidalgo est désormais de montrer la
faisabilité de la mesure sur le plan
économique il reste pour cela plusieurs
mois de campagne
doubler le salaire des profs idée neuve
où il découvre régulièrement dans cette
campagne présidentielle on passera au
crible une proposition de candidats avec
ce titre que vous retrouverez donc de
temps en temps idées neuves ou idées
courtes pour répondre à cette question
j'accueille marie estelle pech bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes rédactrice en chef
au service société du magazine marianne
le sénateur du val-d'oise porte parole
du parti socialiste racheter mal bonjour
bonjour bienvenue matthieu croissandeau
l'éditorialiste de sens public et
évidemment à mes côtés vous partager
l'antenne toute la semaine avec laeticia
cru pas vous êtes l'homme du lundi et du
mercredi exactement c'est un plaisir de
vous accueillir de nouveau avec nous
également déjà pas en visioconférence
ghislaine david qui est co secrétaire
général et porte parole du snuipp-fsu
le sn du pp qui représente les
enseignants du primaire du premier degré
et puis on attend d'une minute à l'autre
gérard longuet le sénateur et l'air de
la meuse qui va nous rejoindre dans un
instant
doubler d'ici à la fin du prochain
quinquennat le traitement de toutes les
personnes au contact avec les élèves
voilà les termes choisis par anne
hidalgo dans son livre je vais démarrer
avec la question du débat idées neuves
ou idées courtes je commence avec vos
mains et sa pêche alors si évidemment on
peut une sorte de copycat de ce qu'ils
avaient de ce que proposent les
socialistes à l'occasion de chaque
élection présidentielle on se souvient
que françois hollande lui avait promis
60000 postes d'enseignants c'est un
copycat dans le sens où il n'est pas
question
aujourd'hui de contrepartie sert qu'on
donne 60 postes pour françois hollande
on double les deux du problème
fondamental qui se posent en france
c'est à dire que on a un effondrement
quand même généralisée du niveau des
élèves on le voit
palmarès après palmarès international
que ce soit bizarre que ce soit d'autres
espèces dévaluation interne à
l'éducation nationale on voit notamment
que le système que le le niveau partie
sous particulièrement en mathématiques
ne cesse de de baisser 1 que ce soit
notamment dans
au niveau des écoles primaires et là
dessus on l'attend quand même aussi
beaucoup sur cette question et là on n'a
pas de on n'a pas de réponse sont deux c
était le problème d'ailleurs du
quinquennat hollande il a il a
effectivement embaucher un certain
nombre d'enseignants
mais on n'a pas eu de véritable
révolution dans le système est
intéressant on y reviendra on y revient
sur la question des contreparties ses
affaires une telle promesse en sang à
mort c'est effectivement une discussion
une négociation et coton entamer une
négociation alors même qu'on a déjà même
a déjà mis sur la table une telle
augmentation on est et on est d'accord
gérard longuet bienvenus merci merci de
participer à ce débat sénateurs l ère de
la meuse ancien ministre de la défense
évidemment et vous avez récemment
présidé une commission sur le déficit
d'attractivité du métier de professeur
de mathématiques vous étiez évidemment à
l'écouté de ce que vient de dire marie
estelle pech j'intitule le voilà je vous
étiez peut-être pas là quand je lui ai
dit mais j on va prendre les promesses
des candidats avec cette question idées
neuves ou idées courtes qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est d'abord une idée
chère cher parce que le doublement de la
masse salariale du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
c'est en gros
buzon sur 60 milliards c'est 55
milliards en plus c'est à dire les trois
quarts de l'impôt sur le revenu donc
c'est quasiment un doublement l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est une idée chère c'est
une idée cours je partage votre
sentiment parce que là la vraie question
est de savoir le problème est-il
générale dans toutes les disciplines
pour quel thème pour quel type
d'activité et que doit faire les
professeurs demain et en particulier
question majeure de leur présence en
heures dans l'établissement et donc ça
risque de faire une promesse comme celle
là sans
négociation deux nuls c'est à dire je
double affiché
négociations superficielle je ne demande
rien contre partie en revanche c'est un
vrai problème il faut savoir et nous
avons trahi sur ce sujet que le pouvoir
d'achat d'un prof de maths puisque
c'était le sujet que le sénat la
commission des finances avait examiné
c'est en france sans quand en allemagne
c'est 150 me dire oui mais les allemands
sont très riches les espagnols qui sont
moins riches que nous payent leur prof
de maths sur une base 130 quand nous
leur donnons sans honte les temps
incontestable
il est incontestable que dans certaines
matières les rémunérations d'enseignants
ne permettent plus de mobiliser de bons
éléments racheter mal vous dites et 9
mois je pense une idée qui répond à une
vraie situation alors j'entends ce qui
était d'ailleurs j'ai ôté votre regard
sur le cas de françois hollande il l'a
fait les soixante mille emplois et il a
fait il ya eu des mesures en face
c'était pas mais ça c'est votre point de
vue donc en soi soit on discute mais je
fais je vous ai pas coupé mais je
pourrais le faire à d'autres proches
intervention c'est clair c'est que il y
avait plus de laives que de profonds
plusieurs de preuve que d'élèves ça a
permis aux jeunes de faire beaucoup de
choses je rappelle par contre vous êtes
très émue et d'ailleurs sur le
quinquennat de monsieur macro comme quoi
il ne s'est rien passé sur ce que vos
amis d'al gore moi je pense qu à deux
choses d'abord moi qui me satisfont la
première c'est que le mot tabou depuis
de nombreuses années dans la politique
française tellement salaire par mois je
suis très content encore pas les
salaires parce que ce qui touche les
français qu'on vous parle avec eux c'est
le salaire donc je veux dire c'est une
vraie avancée je pense qu'il faut le
poser là c'est un vrai débat deux
événements vous l'avez dit vous-même
chers collègues on ne paye pas
suffisamment les profs je rappelle que
les enseignants certaines disent
globalement les enseignants en france
globalement mais si moi je vous le redis
en 1981 quand il rentrait dans la
profession il touchait 2,3 pour deux ou
trois fois le smic aujourd'hui c'est un
verre ou deux il ya une paupérisation
c'est un fait ne veut pas dire à la fois
il ya prés et pis ça c'est le niveau
c'est une porte d'entrée ce que dit anne
hidalgo s'est il ya un sujet qui est
globalement l'école nous sommes tous
d'accord il ya un premier sujet qui est
ce qui en 16 que c'est pas mal de
clients ce qu'ils enseignent qui sont
jolis paupérisée qui sont quand même on
est au 21ème rang de l' ocde si on
double cette mesure là on sera juste au
niveau de l'allemagne est ce qu'on pense
sérieusement que l'allemagne n'est pas
un pays sérieux vertueux en terme de
chance mais la réponse est c'est un
super ac apeis à le bourny crainte
qu'elle compose un enjeu elle dit
l'éducation c'est une clos était la
question des salaires en france c'est
une priorité est donc un porte un
premier alors à près de 2 des craintes
il y aura le temps du projet et il sera
chiffré un aileron était déjà candidate
à paris elle a su démontrer sa capacité
à faire des propositions qui sont
chiffrés et réelle allez on sait que
l'on va pas dire à la fois de l'école et
dire il ne faut rien toucher
suite à ghislaine david donc qu'ils
représentent dans ce débat les
professeurs les premiers concernés par
cette annonce d'anne hidalgo quand vous
avez réagi
vous parlez des cours je pense que c'est
au moins une idée qui permet de parler
puisqu'on est là ce soir pour en parler
et depuis quelques jours je suis
beaucoup d'interviews besson sur cette
question là ce qui montre que il y a un
réel problème des salaires des
enseignants en france alors monsieur
longuet parlait des disciplines moi je
vais pas parler de discipline parce que
je suis professeur des écoles et que je
vais parler au nom des professeurs des
écoles qui sont dans le métier
déniée et qui font comme les professeurs
de mathématiques cinq ans d'études pour
sont recrutés avec 12,5 un master 2 et
que les enseignants ont perdu en pouvoir
d'achat en disant ils ont perdu 15% de
pouvoir d'achat de les milices à 2020
quand on compare comment madame hidalgo
de doubler salaires des enseignants 15
ans de service un enseignant français
est payé 2600 euros brut par mois
lorsqu'un enseignant allemand et payer
105 1200 euros brut par mois donc on
voit bien qu'il ya vraiment un
décrochage avec les pays européens est
on est on a un salaire beaucoup plus
abouti il ya une réelle question des
salaires des enseignants et puis je
lirai le problème avec l'attractivité
des métiers madame tâche dit
effectivement il ya la question de la
réussite et les airs mais il ya la
réussite il ya la question de
l'attractivité de mitsou est un
peu tous étaient vous savez on a du
temps dans ce débat on a quarante
minutes c'est le plaisir de sens public
nos deux débats on a quarante minutes à
chaque fois et on a le temps de creuser
de creuser ses thèmes donc je vous
donnerai évidemment la parole ghislaine
david peut-être et puis on va on va
donner dans le détail ce comparatif
france france europe il y avait dans la
réaction de mylène david mathieu
croissandeau le lire à bas au moins on
en parle depuis depuis deux trois jours
il ya quand même un petit un petit coup
politique de la part de d'anne hidalgo
est ce que vous leur santé comme ça
c'est un coup politique la question
c'est de savoir si les maîtriser parce
que ça interroge sur le fond que sur la
forme sur le fond on l'a dit c'est un
peu curieux d'annoncer une mesure comme
ça defacto parce que c'est une mesure
qui coûte très cher qui va obérer en
grande partie son programme qui empêche
d'une certaine façon toute réflexion sur
le service ou la mission des professeurs
c'est une réponse en fin d'audience une
réponse un peu sur réel ou irréelle un
problème réel et c'est une réponse
uniforme à des situations qui peuvent
être disparate toutes les personnes au
contact des élèves est-ce que ça va être
aussi bien les professeurs d'université
que les professeurs des écoles
c'est une question qui se pose à
laquelle on ne répond pas aujourd'hui
est-ce que les agréger les certifiés
seront traitées de la même façon est-ce
qu'ils auront le même service walla
toute cette réflexion à arriver en
remettant l'argent sur la table je
trouve que ça empêche cette réflexion-là
par ailleurs je trouve que c'est aussi
curieux parce que on entendu annie
d'algos d'hier dimanche qu'elle voulait
aussi augmenté les infirmières les
pompiers et policiers les soldats ça
remet évidemment la question du pouvoir
d'achat et des salaires au coeur du
débat mais avec quel argent on va faire
et la deuxième question sur la forme je
trouve bizarre d'avancé une proposition
aussi précise et sans avoir de billes
derrière ces j'ose dire en disant mais
vous verrez plus tard comme s'il avait
une espèce de suspense où ça sera
chiffré plus tard cette proposition à la
surprise y compris les socialistes vous
le savez
si je juge orie lui je peux vous dire
que j'étais surpris
c'est qu'on le dit sincèrement je pense
qu'il ya deux choses ce que vous êtes
entré dimanche j'avais une intervention
où elle a des classes sa candidature là
ce que vous évoquez c'est dans le cas
d'un dingo ouvrage qui sort aujourd'hui
de passer réfléchie a été lu avant lui
dont justement par rapport à ce que j'ai
c'est bien réfléchi pensé elle dans cet
ouvrage à elle donné l'idée grands
lignes directrices dire aujourd'hui en
début de campagne la question des
salaires et l'éducation sont prises dès
mes priorités du quinquennat je trouve
ça bien et viendra le temps du projet
rassurez-vous sûr il y aura des mesures
mais parce que là j'ai le sentiment que
c'est le cercle de la raison un rappel
balladur dire on peut pas faire si on
dit ça c'est ce qu'on a eu en fait non
générant une chose rassurez vous c'est
une question de choix c'est tout qui se
moqueront par exemple lui l'a fait la
suppression la th 21 milliards liés à
16,5 milliards ça faisait oui tout de
suite plusieurs mines a posé laisser
chaque président ait décidé transsene
dizaine première de aussi ça c'est ce
que vous attendez attendez le chiffrage
ton équipe
non parce que
j'ai recollé vous avez pris l'ensemble
d'une l'ensemble du personnel sait pas
ce qu'elle dit donc je vois bien que
monsieur blanc caire fait monsieur blanc
caire haut lieu de s'occuper du
chiffrage et autres faut d'ailleurs pas
rapidement ils feraient mieux de
s'occuper de la crise pas facile depuis
cinq ans y ont depuis cinq ans de ce qui
se passe dans une casserole et si on est
pour tout le monde non mais c'est pas
alors qu'elles sont en lien avec ceux
qui sont prêts dès
soit ira mesurer tous les ouailles
rassurer il ya le temps du débat qui va
s'engager soyez rassurés il y aurait un
projet chiffré vous parce que vous êtes
vous souhaitez la droite c'est un autre
débat mais aujourd'hui je sais aussi
compté pour nous
rassurer vous madame fonctionnement
mégot est une personne qui s'éclate été
réélu
de seconde j'étais mal n'y a pas que la
droite qui critiquent tiens on va
écouter jean luc
mélenchon lui aussi il fait le
rassurer
on sait pas très bien comment calculer
parce qu'elle elle dit ça fait 9000
enfin bref peu importe son compte elle
s'adonne 100 milliards nous on est parti
des payes dans le budget de l'état de
l'éducation nationale et comme l a dit
que c'était tout ce qui était en face
des élèves donc ça veut dire 93 % de la
dépense actuel de l'êta et ben x
2 pour tous les profs ça vous donne 60
milliards c'est pas rien admettez que
c'est une somme qui mérite débat 1 voilà
donc comme ça pouf g syndicats il
demande de rattraper le gel du point
d'indicé qui a dure depuis dix ans à
l'initiative des socialistes et puis de
faire une augmentation de salaire ça je
suis d'accord total 17 milliards à ce
pacte a fait la somme et il faut les
trouver on va les trouver il faut les
trouver est-ce que vous avez essayé de
de calculer ce que pourrait donner la
promesse de campagne de moi j'ai calculé
que ça correspondait à plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros par an
trouve effectivement mais bon encore une
fois pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
veut faire que propose le parti
socialiste en dehors de cet effectif en
cette augmentation miraculeuse que
effectivement les syndicats n'ont
eux-mêmes jamais réclamé les syndicats
d'enseignants n'ont jamais réclamé
d'avoir des un doublement de leur
salaire ils demandent plutôt le dégel du
point d'indicé je crois que nous dotant
d'une seule pièce là qui faisait la
comparaison avec les autres pays
européens et qui demande à ce que d'être
alliés donc je crois que vous n'êtes pas
dans le
pur à d'hidalgo et les socialistes lol
sur les la question du casier je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord qui est un
problème sur l'éducation autres pays et
qu'il faut vraiment y travaille et on
est tous d'accord vous l'avez dit
l'étude pisa ce il ya moins de la
vocation il ya une crise des vocations
d'accord de ça ils partent de là à part
cela c'est un des éléments mais il y
aura d'autres éléments l'excellence pour
tous les élèves il ya plein de choses à
faire la question des moyens pour les
enseignants la question des moyens pour
les élèves comment on fait en sorte que
deux enfants qui rentrent en scène
scolaire et ben à la fin il n ya pas
encore une différentiel dit à l'origine
sur la c'est ça qui sera le débat
vous parlez de l'allemagne on se compare
tout le temps à l'allemagne maintient
l'espagne le portugal on pouvait le
battre pardon
c'est le thème de la chronique de
quentin carnaille rejoice heureux
rejoignez-nous quentin donc la rédaction
de public sénat qui tous les jours dans
cette émission nous propose un zoom
voilà une chronique très factuelle dont
vous avez fait ce comparatif cantat
bonsoir effectivement ça tout le monde
d'accord les enseignants français sont
ne sont pas les mieux lotis et de loin
voilà sur cette question des salaires il
ya une étude de référence c'est celle de
l' ocde on va regarder elle compare la
situation de 38 pays développés le
constat est le plus sévère pour le début
de carrière avec les enseignants
français au collège qui pointe à la 20e
position des rémunérations nous sommes
dans la moyenne très basse de ces pays
c'est 38 pays on a regardé également la
moyenne des salaires de ses enseignants
du secondaire la comparer avec d'autres
pays européens thomas et bien même en
milieu de carrière où il est chaussé
graphique les profs français sont moins
bien rémunérés qu'au luxembourg en
allemagne aux pays bas en espagne en
belgique sur les pays de l'union
européenne eh bien on pointe à la 8e
place la rémunération des professeurs
qui est même en baisse depuis
1982 on a trouvé cet article de
libération qui cite un chercheur qui
donne le chiffre d'une baisse des
salaires de 28% entre 1982 et 2018 c'est
dû à l'inflation qui est plus forte que
les primes qui ont été annoncées d'année
en année les ministres de l'éducation
nationale évidemment a fait une nouvelle
annonce en faveur des salaires est ce
que ce suivi pour rattraper le retard
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que au début
du quinquennat c'est uniquement les
salaires des enseignants en rep qui
avait été revalorisée réseau des voies
lation prix en zone d'éducation est
exactement l'année dernière il y avait
bien eu une hausse plus générale des
salaires savez représenter 400 millions
d'euros dans le budget de l'état et à la
fin du grenelle de l'éducation c'était
en mai dernier le ministre a annoncé une
nouvelle hausse de 500 millions d'euros
alors avec un objectif affiché en plus
vous le voyez c'est bien à l'horizon
2024 d'avoir un salaire minimum de 2000
euros nets pour tous professeurs et or
les ministres inquiète aussi également
lancé un observatoire des salaires il
était installé à l'été dernier en tout
cas effectivement ottoman on peut lire
l'attractivité de ce métier c'est un
enjeu fondamental monsieur longuet vous
l'amènerai dans un rapport d'ailleurs
qu'on a lu quand on sait qu'on a du mal
à recruter des profs en mathématiques en
physique ou à l'informatique merci
quentin pour ce zoom on vous retrouve
dans notre second débat tout à l'heure
vous faire un aveu quand on est tous
masqués à la rédaction de public sénat
c'est après une fois que je le visage
complet de quentin calmer et ça fait ça
fait du bien gérard longuet sûr je
reviens sur cette cette notion-là de
comparatif on est tous d'accord vous
l'avez dit spontanément les uns et les
autres dans vos premières interventions
bon si vous dites doubler le salaire
c'est pas possible c'est illusoire ça va
nous obliger à augmenter les impôts
d'une façon insupportable c'est quoi la
solution pour vous qui avez étudié cette
question alors contrairement à ce qu'a
dit madame notre syndicaliste il faut
avoir un examen par discipline il y à
des disciplines qui sont fortement
déficitaires et pour lesquelles on ne
parvient pas à recruter et c'est
d'ailleurs tout à fait normal parce
qu'il ya un déficit de candidats
étudiants dans les disciplines
mathématiques scientifiques et physique
c'est vrai pour les ingénieurs et nous
risquons d'avoir une pénurie
d'ingénieurs en france c'est vrai pour
les enseignants en mathématiques et en
ce qui concerne les enseignants
mathématiques irait concurrence du
secteur privé si vous avez une licence
de maths l'informatique est beaucoup
plus intéressante que l'enseignement bon
c'est un premier problème deuxième
problème de discipline madame a dit je
suis professeur des écoles je suis
interdisciplinaire c'est malheureusement
faux les professeurs des écoles c'est de
dire l'enseignement primaire et composer
pour 80 % 90 % de candidats qui viennent
de formation littéraire or en effet les
professeurs des écoles en scène et
mathématiques mais ils n'ont pas la
culture des mathématiques et ils ont
souvent en force est de le reconnaître
une sorte d'appréhension vis-à-vis des
élèves comme ils n'ont pas d'appétence
pour la matière ils ne parviennent pas
le transformer altran a mobilisé leurs
élèves iront sur ce sujet l'une des
explications ou en mathématiques frise
l'air et nous avons pareil enfin une
pédagogie de l'enseignement des
mathématiques qui semblerait pour voir
s'améliorer singulièrement en rendant
les mathématiques à la fois plus simple
et plus joyeuse et elles ne sont ni
simple ni joyeuse et défendu par des
professeurs qui n'ont pas de facilités
avec la réponse de ghislaine david
évidemment vous étiez à l'ecoute de deux
de ses critiques exprimées par gérard
longuet pas et s'imposent les relations
je vous ai alors je sais pas si c'est un
débat sur les enseignants ont des
mathématiques sur le salaire des
enseignants moi je vous le dit qu'elle
très clairement spi lueur enseignante en
école primaire donc j'enseigne toutes
les disciplines monsieur longuet a
raison sur une chose c'est que quand on
va quand on a un master de science on a
plus de possibilité d'avoir un meilleur
salaire dans le privé ou dans une autre
fonction que dans l'enseignement donc
effectivement on a des enseignants qui
ne sont pas des enseignants
scientifiques qui vont enseigner dans le
premier degré après on a aussi des
enseignants qui suivraient un
enseignement scientifique et qui veulent
enseigner à des jeunes élèves donc ils
vont se diriger vers l'enseignement on
en a quand même quelques uns ça fait pas
tout la question de de la discipline on
sait que parce que parce que évidemment
où j'enseigne toutes les disciplines je
suis désolé de le dire mais quand je
suis enseignante ans même si certains le
coeur de notre débat pardon de vous
intéresser talent qui anticipa d'une on
a quand même qu'est ce que j'aimerais ça
matrix que dit gérard longuet pas assez
joyeux pas assez simple l'enseignement
des maths
discussion effectivement on pourrait
avoir un débat sur l'enseignement des
mathématiques soit la formation des
enseignants c'est aussi ça c'est à dire
que quand on est enseignant actuellement
il n'a pas de formation continue la
formation continue est complètement
inexistante donc on a besoin de ce
retour en formation et effectivement
quand on ne maîtrise pas un certain
nombre de compétences telles que les
mathématiques sont les qu'il ne maîtrise
pas bien il faut pouvoir être formés à
l'enseignement des mathématiques parce
qu'on n'enseigne pas les maîtres m de la
même façon en grande section de
maternelle comme en cm2 comme en 6e ou
en terminale donc il faut avoir une
formation spécifique qu'on a pas
suffisamment c'est aussi un autre
problème ça la formation des enseignants
mais je pense que c'est pas non plus le
débat mais quand on parle de messi on a
droit aujourd'hui de mettre là le pire
c'est pas le débat mais si on a de
l'argent et pour mieux le mettre là
qu'est ce que vous répondez sur la
formation je pense que c'est un tout
c'est à dire que vous avez parlé je suis
qui disait tout à l'heure la question
des gars la question des salaires mais
alors est-ce là la question notamment
les conditions de travail des
enseignants vous avez raison il ya la
question de la formation des enseignants
il faut il mettre le paquet est
certainement sur la formation des
enseignants il ya un certain nombre
d'éléments qui permettrait de faire
évoluer le système mais je veux revenir
quand même sur l'attractivité du métier
notamment sur les professeurs des écoles
actuellement et c'est le cas cette année
à la rentrée on est obligé de recruter
les enseignants contractuels parce qu'on
n'a pas assez le candidat aux concours
de recrutement des enseignants et ça
c'est problématique mais ces problèmes à
les marier c'est bien rennes qu'elle
soit il encore faut-il préciser quand
même que willy à un défaut
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
mais de quel de quoi parle-t-on il ya un
défaut d'attractivité par exemple
concernant les professeurs des écoles
sur certains territoires en
ile-de-france force landes depuis cette
année depuis cette année là n tech
regardez les on recrute des contractuels
dans pratiquement tous les départements
c'est nettement moins le cas quand même
dans le piège des départements qui sont
chères
la seine saint denis on sait que c'est
endémique star qu'on a énormément de mal
c'est nettement moins le cas dans le sud
de la france qui est beaucoup plus
attractif et aujourd'hui ça devient de
plus en plus osés c'est de plus en plus
le cas y compris dans des départements
très attractive concernant le concerne
les disciplines à y parle beaucoup des
matraques des maths mais vous avez des
disciplines qu'ils n'ont aucune
difficulté à attirer des enseignants
dont vous d'ici là et l'autre il faut il
faut pas promettre à tout le monde et il
faut du quartier qu'il faut peut-être
voir effectivement en effectivement au
cas par cas rachid tu es mal non mais je
sais très intéressant mais quand vous
êtes enseignant aujourd'hui si je prends
l'île de france ce n'est que 12 millions
d'habitants en ile-de-france il ya un
problème pour se loger par exemple
conséquence évidemment donc donc là au
regard des salaires ils font parfois les
enseignants plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres chaque jour pour voir entre
leur lieu de résidence d'habitation et
le mode où il enseigne c'est des choses
comme ça aussi simple que ça dormoy
jours encore une fois il ya un problème
de salaires dans notre pays en général
et pour les enseignants en particulier
oui après enfin plein d'autres débats
mais ça c'est le premier point deuxième
point vous l'évoquez monsieur longuet
c'était là vous et quand on est quand on
sort de l'école dans le privé on gagne
eux que dans l'éducation si nous
considérons dans un pays comme le nôtre
que l'éducation fait tout parce que
c'est ducation comme sera demain dans
des ingénieurs et ben alors il faut
s'assurer que les meilleurs d'entre nous
soient enseignants c'est ça l'enjeu qui
est aussi posée par la pression d'anne
hidalgo c'est faire encore une fois
l'éducation certes magnifiques
d'excellents visite que l'éducation ça a
été votre chance
et bien sûr moi je rajoute pas des
matelas mais moi mes parents viennent
d'algérie ils ont pas eu la chance à
l'école donc j'ai les valeurs qu'ils
m'ont enseigné mais je sais que l'école
m'a apporté beaucoup c'est des
enseignants des rencontres et
aujourd'hui on voit bien le niveau il ya
un sujet que aujourd'hui en france quand
vous êtes dans le val d'oise à certains
endroits ou à henri iv vous n'avez pas
de l'enseignement faisons pas semblant
de croire tout que c'était pas vrai et
que oui effectivement dites moi ce que
je souhaite c'est pas que les quatre
meilleurs du val d'oise à et henri iv je
souhaite qu'il mêle niveau aussi
possiblement dont le val d'oise en
seine-saint-denis où henri iv
plusieurs
lots salaires y contribuer est ce que
les profs sont mal payés oui est-ce que
les situations sont disparates oui
est-ce qu'il faut la même réponse pour
tout le monde non mais
faut rémunérer par exemple de la même
façon un enseignant qui s'inscrit dans
le projet d'établissement et un
enseignant qui se contente de venir
faire ses heures et de se marier
vous avez vision
est ce que vous parlais juste venaient
rémunérer de la même manière est-ce
qu'il faut agir de la même manière des
directoires école vous avez dans des
écoles moi je vais dans les écoles on
voit bien l'engagement des en juin bien
leur engagement est ce qu'ils font mais
on peut dire que toulalan travaille de
la même manière pas avec la même
application je suis juste une question
est-ce qu'il faut rémunérer de la même
manière ceux qui s'inscrivent qui se
faisait monter sur coup dans un projet
d'établissement et ceux qui dégomment
ans sans salaire de base la formation
excusez moi qui assure l information ce
pays aux enseignants parce qu'à l'époque
à l'époque avait dû les faits mais un
parcours également qu'il a supprimé
5 s'cusez moi des connaissances ça ne
fait pas l'enseigné
formation des gens de l'époque on
apprenait à l'enseigné
soit tous en même temps
si je reprends un tout petit peu la main
excusez moi parce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui m'intéresse dans ce que matthieu
croissandeau a dit sur le fait de nommer
parce que vous y avez pas répondu vous
avez fait riper le débat sur la
formation s'est il y dit il dit il faut
pas rémunérer tous les profs de la même
façon peut-être qu'il faut introduire le
jeu par fall mais une notion de mérite
quoi c'est à dire que certains soient
mieux payés que d'autres en fonction de
l'engagement le travail et la vie
difficile qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ces ya deux choses d'abord le rendu
accord que pour faire cela
déjà la base mais d'accord qu'il faut
augmenter les profs c'est ce que j'ai
dit est ce que les pros sont michael ben
oui d'accord donc mais pas les profs
c'est pas la même chose professeurs des
écoles dont il est donc représentée par
madame david sont effectivement très mal
lotis alors les cas sont avec actions
seront payées dans votre après le
secondaire
les entrants dans la profession c'est
vrai les professeurs des écoles c'est
vrai pas encore vraiment
particulièrement mal rémunérés par
exemple les professeurs du secondaire
ont des primes il peut faire des heures
supplémentaires ils ont des primes de
professeur principal de professeurs
principaux et c'est vous avez aussi des
agrégés qui sont quand même quitte corps
tralala vous êtes déjà sur des petites
parties le
canton vous dis là c'est qu'on vous dit
c'est pas parce que ces déchets pour
donner votre journaliste et que
aujourd'hui encore une fois à l'époque
ont commencé à 2 ou 3 fois le smic
aujourd'hui indien ou deux ça c'est une
donnée
donc oui à l'appui ce que vous croyez
que non non c'est pas qu'il a augmenté
voilà donc le poids d'achat à 10 me à la
fin c'est le constat est le même donc
moi je suis pour d'abord l'augmentation
à la presse oui de tous déçu bien sûr
moi je connais pas de bons enseignants
qu'ils soient sous qu'ils soient
surveillés ou alors je vous parle pas de
du dugas qui est agrégé qui fait encore
jaser
réglages et
[Musique]
j'en suis incapable on se retrouve au
même niveau
global exact est passé d'un faisceau
global allait nous moi je ne souhaite
pas par dernier voilà je ne souhaite pas
qui est cette politique encore une fois
à la fin où on sait par decaux
d'établissement établissements des
portiques tarifs des pôles chez les
politiques salariales ça je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ça parce que je pense et
ça commence à dénombrer c'est déjà ce
qui se passe pour le mieux pour le bac
je rappelle que pour le bac on a des
options souffre encore une fois henri iv
ou par exemple au lycée louis jouvet à
taverny vous n'avez pas les mêmes
options et donc l'enfant n'a pas les
mêmes
c'est à dire c'est à dire il n'y a pas
la même culture transmise je suis ça
c'est un autre sujet oui oui oui sauf
que l'éducation justement doit permettre
d'arrêter cela c'est parce que dans
notre vision ben voilà c'est là on a une
vraie différence voilà pourquoi moi je
crois que je suis de gauche et l'école à
jour ou le mouchage aussi la gauche il
ya des gens qui pourraient
également désormais dire
non c'est intéressant donc ils ont des
convictions autre exemple d'un pratique
elle même parcours que vous ses parents
ont choisi de l'envoyer à l'école privée
pour qu'elle réussit et moi c'est une
forme on voit l'école publique et j'ai
réussi moi je joue mieux moi je sois
l'amour l'école publique et du sahel
souligne
je ne serais pas là aujourd'hui dans
votre système
départ faire avancer un peu le débat si
vous voulez bien je vous ai mille fois
raison aux uns et aux autres monsieur
longuet merci parce que je voudrais
qu'on rebondisse sur une proposition du
président de la république cette fois-ci
emmanuel macron qui veut expérimenter la
liberté du choix des enseignants par les
directeurs d'établissement c'était la
semaine dernière à marseille écoutait
faut qu'on ait des directeurs d'école à
qui on permet d'avoir un peu plus
d'encadrement
faut que ces directeurs d'école et
puissent choisir l'équipe pédagogique en
quelque sorte d'avoir une équipe qui
n'est pas simplement fait d'enseignants
mais de pouvoir d'abord
choisir les enseignants qui sont être
sûrs qu'ils sont pleinement motivé
qu'ils adhèrent au projet ce qui est je
crois normal parce que c'est dur est de
pouvoir aussi y associer
des acteurs extra scolaires qu'ils
partagent l'objectif
cette école là complètement elle
n'existe pas en france aujourd'hui et je
me tourne vers ghislaine david qui est
avec toi en visioconférence vous dit que
c'est une mesure dangereuse pourquoi
c'est dangereux
oui tout à fait c'est une mesure
dangereuse en tout cas
la mesure qui a été annoncé ce qu'il
était une annonce de du président en
campagne on va dire du président
maquereau en campagne
d'abord il ya aucun pouvoir hiérarchique
actuellement du directeur d'école sur
les enseignants donc on inclure elle a
une mesure qui est complètement hors
cadre à elle et elle n'est pas dans dans
l'est de l'île dans le statut est l une
des cinq ans vous dit dangereux ces
dangereuses pour qui pour les profs ou
pour les effets dangereux parce que moi
je la très clairement je vais vous le
dire comment ça va se passer à marseille
on va avoir une école à deux vitesses
n'est mise en concurrence des écoles
c'est à dire que d'autant que le
président accroc dans son discours dit
les enseignants ne sont pas engagés dans
leurs établissements et dans leur école
il sous-entend que ceux qui sont dans
les écoles de marseille ne sont pas
engagés dans les projets je rappelle que
toutes les écoles primaires maternelles
et des projets d'école et les
enseignants
s'organise au sein du projet d'école
pour développer des ouailles tous dans
l'engagement auprès de nos élèves et
pour l'heure et la réussite des élèves
enfin donc on a un engagement
la question de nommer les enseignants
par directeur d'école est quelque chose
de complètement arbitraire et subjective
sur quels critères on va recruter ces
enseignants j'entendais je vous entendez
dire tout à l'heure il faudrait du
mérite et l'engagement dans le projet
comment on vérifie l'engagement dans le
projet il ya il ya enfin c'est qu'elle
essaie des mesures qui sont très
subjectifs actuellement les règles de la
fonction publique c'est de pouvoir
ça veut dire que les professeurs se
valent vous pouvez pas dire si le fameux
système par points de l'éducation
nationale qui rend malheureuse laisser
c'est pas un système par points son
avance à l'ancienne qu'il est seul on a
des affinités musicales variées où celle
ci un jury mais c'est le service public
c'est à dire que c'est l'égalité sur le
territoire pour tous les enseignants
mais aussi pour tous les âges
à l'égalité sur tous les toits mais
merci de ce point de vue gérard longuet
sur cette mesure vraiment précise
proposer ce test proposé par le
président va lire c'est une demande très
forte d'un certain nombre de think tank
de droite depuis quarante ans je crois
que le président m'a compte découvre une
idée simple qui est que la
responsabilité d'un établissement passe
par le choix des enseignants simplement
c'est une idée révolutionnaire et ne
venant de président en exercice
on se pose la question de savoir si la
mesure est la totalité des conséquences
de cette orientation elle ne me choque
pas sur le principe mais c'est plus
l'éducation nationale c'est une
éducation décentralisées comme on la
trouve dans d'autres pays d'europe et
une fois de plus comme on la trouve en
allemagne où comme on la trouve dans
l'enseignement privé
les chefs d'établissement dans
l'enseignement privé effectivement rose
choisissent mais aussi julie - plus ou
moins parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas
forcément toujours le choix en vérité et
puis les lycées français de l'étranger
aussi qui sont publiques
les chefs d'établissement font
d'ailleurs c'est des entretiens par
vidéo interposée pour fermer des moyens
dont il manque des moyens des leurs pour
l'établissement
dans certains états
suscitent pas ça ne suscite pas de
polémique dans les lycées français de
l'étranger
ce qui est vrai et ce qui est vrai là
dessus les syndicats d'enseignants ont
raison c'est que si vous allez en seine
saint denis et vous mettez en place ce
système du choix du chef d'établissement
ou non en fait ils n'auront il n'aura
jamais le choix le chef d'état disant
parce que ça non
pourra jamais faire venir les meilleurs
ou les plus d'expérience on les paye il
soigne t il aux puces ou alors foulée
piller le russe et on met encore viala
profil elle est passée bien que
salariale différenciée une voie là on
met en place des postes à profil on
multiplie les postes à profil c'est ce
qu'a l'air de vouloir faire macron
effectivement à marseille puisqu'il
s'agit pour l'instant d'une expérience
on ne sait pas si ça va marcher ou pas
là ça j'ai choisi va le faire d'abord on
ne sait pas s'il va le faire et si l'on
capacité de le faire et de toute façon
ici c'est la wii ce que ça peut
peut-être fonctionner je ne sais pas
c'est que ce n'est pas un territoire qui
manque d'enseignants ou qui manque
d'attractivité donc il aura peut-être la
possibilité il se les chefs
d'établissement ont peut-être la
possibilité là bas de choisir un peu
plus leur enseignante je pense qu'il ya
deux questions il ya la question d'abord
du ch du directeur de l'école ou pas moi
je suis là très milan étant dans ma
famille politique ce que je crois qu'ils
abandonnaient directeur me pose la
question de diriger branchement qui a
une vraie question de responsabilité
d'un directeur ou directrice donc plus
d'autonomie plus à pouvoir non mais déjà
d'autres parce qu'aujourd'hui de fait ne
te fait aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
direction de cirque
dont vous
sur l'autonomie excusez-moi cirque on
imagine très sérieusement que le pr le
directeur la directrice va face et va
recruter des enseignants sur quelle base
sur un système comand
c'est parce que des présents présent et
10 et donc la liberté de recruter de
recruter je m'excuse c'est ce qu'il dit
moi je suis pas favorable à stains parce
que encore une fois qu'est-ce qui me
garantit je reprends toujours mon
exemple surprenant c'est surprenant bien
sûr qu'est-ce qui me garantit qu'il y
allait même chose pour les enfants
encore une fois je reprends un lycée
dans le val d'oise et america c'est
illusoire
peut-être oui peut-être vous et déjà on
peut être moi je ne joue pas au
peut-être avec la vie des enfants et
d'un système éducatif c'est tout la
différence parce que ça c'est une vraie
question si vous garantissez que
effectivement il ya le même niveau la
même chance pour tous les enfants de
france je suis prêt
longuet à l'honnêteté de dire qu à un
moment donné c'est définitif de droite
qui pose ça ça s'appelle ça s'appelle en
fait à la déréglementation l'intérieur
est un peu ça comme on veut non mais les
résultats éducation prioritaire parce
que je ne sais pas si c'est parce qu'il
ya trop développée il ya trop de
saupoudrage un masque humain dans ses
réseaux là dans ces réseaux l'argent on
est très très loin du petit frère mais
ya pas suffisamment
12 enfants par classe et il y en a il ya
ce n'est même pas encore partout sur le
territoire concerné dont moi je veux
bien qu'on regarde et grande médaille et
décide de monsieur blanc qu'elle
dédoublement je suis d'accord c'est pour
sa jolie s'est pas encore assez mais
encore une fois moi aujourd'hui ce
système là de jeu choisi je prends un
exemple qui est autre chose pour les
employés caricaturable dernier mot la
police municipale s'est même système
puisque chacun il ya une concurrence
d'une ville à l'autre
dont gilles me de résultat des courses
et c'est pour ça que ça marche je suis
pas sûr donc comment on fait dans un
encore une fois dans un endroit avec
moins de moyens des difficultés face
endroit où tout va bien si vous vous
garantissez le même niveau de chance
pour chaque élève et d'enseignement je
prédis que je crois que tout le monde a
eu la possibilité s'exprimer longuement
merci à tous les quatre je remercie
évidemment guerdavid également d'avoir
participé à ce débat